patience is one of the great ways to be  nice to oneself you may like yourself in  a confidence that right but that you're  beating your the reason you're upset  about them is you think it's complacency  while you still have a lot of ambition  which is why I pound into people's  [ __ ] skull at 31 years old was on the  floor in a liquor store helping people  who walked in I was retail everybody is  playing their 20s backwards everybody's  got such a chip on their shoulder  between debt or to prove to somebody  that they've got something you can  literally literally [ __ ] live for the  next 10 years do nothing right I'm  [ __ ] wet you're putting too much  pressure on yourself don't let anybody  else's [ __ ] clock you know dictate  your game you've got [ __ ] 60 [ __ ]  years of execution in front of you